je ne vois pas pourquoi les martiniquais
n'aurait pas droit à lire dans le
journal ce que peuvent lire en clair les
guadeloupéens comme on dit aux antilles
tout moun semoun
alors bonjour à tous bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui c'est un jour est un jour un
peu sombre quand même parce que c'est un
jour de censure aujourd'hui alors dans
vif du sujet tout de suite voilà ici le
journal l'édition papier du front sont
ils qui est du vendredi 26 samedi 27
dimanche 28 mars donc c'est à dire la
semaine dernière et dans cette dans
cette édition papier paru en guadeloupe
il y à un article qui est à la page 7
qui dit 1,17 milliard d'euros ont été
alloués à la filière banane sous entendu
ces 13 dernières années avec un article
pleines pages qui explique un petit peu
comment fonctionne la filière banane et
surtout avec les prolongements de cette
filière banane en afrique
eh bien figurez vous que cette édition a
mis martiniquais vous ne la verrez
jamais parce que cette édition elle a
été censurée sur pression des puissances
d'argent de la martinique est bien
france antilles n'a pas publié
cet article en martinique donc publié
dans l'édition papier de guadeloupe est
censuré en martinique nous chers et
d'hommes
on est des lanceurs dallaire alors on
peut être d'accord ou ne pas être
d'accord avec nous mais ce qui est clair
c'est que quand on est dans la censure
c'est inacceptable car c'est une
atteinte à la démocratie
et si moi je suis censuré vous êtes
censuré alors vous savez évidemment
jamais quand vous êtes censuré mais ça
veut dire que beaucoup d'informations
qui devrait venir au peuple n'y arrive
pas parce que certains les puissances
d'argent de martinique considère que ça
pourrait déranger leur business ce
qu'est le cas de cet article
- je vais vous dire la martinique n'est
pas une république bananière
n'en déplaise aux puissances d'argent de
la martinique
la martinique n'est pas une république
bananière et chacun a droit à l'égalité
devant l'information
je ne vois pas pourquoi les martiniquais
n'aurait pas droit à lire dans le
journal ce que peuvent
en clair les guadeloupéens comme on dit
aux antilles tout moun semoun on doit
avoir cette égalité
donc aujourd'hui nous prenons
aujourd'hui encore plus qu'avant ce
combat ce combat qui est un combat pour
la démocratie
c'est un combat pour la vérité c'est un
combat que nous menons pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait de plus en plus
d'égalité en matière économique il n'y a
pas d'égalité aujourd'hui économique et
la pression que viennent mettre
aujourd'hui les puissances d'argent sur
un média pour nous couper la parole
montre bien à quel point nous avons
raison de dénoncer ce que nous dénonçons
le combat continue à bientôt
on ne va pas s'arrêter là